Let's go to Scott from Trenton.
Scott from Trenton.
What is on your mind?
I. Good morning.
Hear me?
Yes, I can hear you.
Excellent.
I just wanted to know.
Coming from I am from Canada, and I'm just
wondering how you have 40 percent of the population
who actually supports Donald Trump.
And what do you think that they're going to
do, say when?
By when?
So this is Trenton, Ontario.
Is that what's going on?
Yes.
OK.
I couldn't see it.
I assumed it was maybe New Jersey.
It would be.
Right.
There's a Trenton in New Jersey, I think,
in any case.
Listen, I understand your shock and amazement
that, you know, tens of millions of people
in this country are voting for Donald Trump.
I have raised this issue many times.
If Biden wins and let's not assume.
But if Biden wins.
What happens to those 60 million people in
the interim period between Election Day and
Inauguration Day?
I believe there's a real possibility that
they become violent, including with firearms.
Beyond that.
I don't know what happens.
You know, they I think a lot of them are going
to pretend like they never really supported
Trump.
Some of them may split off into some kind
of Q and on conspiracy rabbit hole that maybe
at some point will become a more formal political
movement.
Is very, very difficult to say.
But there are going to be here and we're going
to have to deal with it as a country.
And I don't know exactly how we do that.
I just I watch your show or listen to your
show all the time, and I'm just genuinely
concerned that.
The U.S. has withdrawn its role as being the
leader of the free world, and yet.
What's what's going to like?
I just don't know how it proceeds or progresses
from here.
I don't know either.
I'm so what I'm trying to do is to take it
step by step.
Have I voted?
Yes.
OK.
I did that.
Next, let's see what happens on Tuesday.
And then we'll continue to make plans after
that.
In a while.
Big fan, thanks for taking my call.
Appreciate it.
Great
to hear
from you very, very much.